- She was just like listen,
I think I should just cut this off now.
Like you're great,
but you're not what I'm looking for.
I'm really sorry.
So, I ended up going to
the game with a friend
later that night.
I looked up at the kiss
cam and there she was
with some other guy at the game.
(laughing)
- Happy Valentine's day.
I'm Mikala and I'm gonna go
around and ask my co-workers
what's your most depressing
story about love.
I'm also gonna make them
wear this (bleep) hat
so they realize how
(bleep) stupid they are
for falling in love in the first place.
After hearing all their
depressing (bleep) stories,
you'll be happy you're single.
- How do I?
- [Man] Yeah.
It's very upsetting.
- In high school,
we used to do this thing where you could
buy roses for people and they
would get delivered in class.
And you'd be like super
popular if you got some.
And no one ever sent me any (bleep) roses.
So, I made up names and
sent some to myself.
- [Girl] Ohh!
- Don't oof my, Ashley!
- Whatever, (bleep)
looked cool for the day.
And self love is the best kind of love.
Am I right?
- My most depressing story about love
is that I spent most of my life
like pining after random
dudes who didn't care
and then they ended up dating my friends.
But, one day you'll find love.
It'll be fine.
- I was an amusement park with my friends
and I was with one of my guy friends.
And he does this.
And what I'm thinking he's
doing is well come on!
Turns out what he was
doing was putting his hands
just in his pocket.
When he realized what I was doing
he was like uh uh.
Instead of taking that as a physical hint
to stop what I'm doing,
I just forced my arm in
between his arm and his torso
until finally I was like oh!
- So, I went through his phone
and I was like searching
for a name, right?
And I couldn't find anything
so I was like let's get creative.
So, I searched for the word babe.
And I put search and I found
all the different times
that he had called somebody else babe.
So, I found that he was
talking to this other guy.
I decided I was like
maybe okay we can like
get past this.
And when I decided to lay next to him,
the bed broke in half down the middle.
Ikea beds, you know?
And then we just decided to
breakup and that was that.
- Yo, a disclaimer.
It was mad petty and I was mad young.
I put that (bleep) in there.
I was mad young.
Ah yo, she used to come in the home late.
I'm like take a shower
before you go to bed.
I'm big on that.
But she ain't do it
and she used to work in the restaurant.
And then one day I woke up,
there was a piece of chicken on my bed.
And then we broke up.
(laughing)
- And honestly I was offended
because just let me hold
your arm you (bleep) hole.
We're friends.
Whatever.
I haven't talked to him since.
I hope he sees this
and I hope he hates where he's at in life.
I'm just kidding.
I hope he's happy or whatever.
(sigh) I don't.
I don't, I don't want
everyone to be happy.